so uh
this was one of my i really enjoyed this
story there's so many great stories but
this is the one of his this is like his
first time dealing drugs so i think it's
a good kind of teaser for the special
for you to want to get further into it
but this is really kind of his uh
10 year old
uh what is it coming out party as a as
he says a pharmaceutical street
rep so here we go
i know i know people thinking well i
ain't really just heard nothing that bad
just yet about your daddy your daddy
just seemed like a
normal delusional bachelor
so
okay been living with this man a little
bit
and
i'm asleep
the pacing
and the man comes in this is like about
the third month end million just made
about three months
this was the really the first site i
just went on home
that man walked in my room
really it was his weight room that he
turned into my room
walked into my room
and said hey
i'm asleep 12 30
in the am the man say stay here look
here
you you sleep
i said i said yeah what's up he said man
look here
i'm about to go out of town
[Laughter]
man
i got to go to school and watch it i
know you got to go to school i said i'm
going downtown
so so what what am i what am i about to
do
should you gonna stay here are you gonna
go to school
do i walk you to school in the morning i
said no
go to school eat you some fruit oats
where you go
eat some food
i said
you leaving me here though
but you scared i said yes
i ain't never been down for myself
before what's wrong with you
my daddy
said i you scared and pulls out
a two-shot
derivative
black and white pearl handle he's saying
now he'll if somebody come in the house
you know what to do i said no i do not
know what you do
who you been talking to they told you i
know what to do
i am ten i do not know what to do
you say now look
that's all preliminary i got some other
things i need you to do
now
it's gonna be
at this back door
some people
gonna knock on their back
keep the chain on the door
it's gonna be fifteen dollars
get their money
go upstairs you get the stuff
get that to them close the door lock it
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
so it's about 12 35 he's gone
i'm thinking
my daddy playing
do
[Laughter]
i get sent to the office for sleeping in
class
i get home my daddy
is sitting at the table
why
am i receiving phone calls
from the school
talking about you being sleeping class
i said i don't know if you check your
little box upstairs
but your little box is full of money
[Applause]
the detail the physicality the pacing
the timing like it all just
really good
such a good